I think people now are more afraid of
death than they've ever been because
they're not familiar with it because it
seems like this exotic other if every
single person who's ever lived has died
it can't be that bad right I can't
imagine how one wouldn't be fascinated
by death my name is Johanna AB neustine
I'm the creative director and co-founder
of the morbid anatomy museum the name
morbid Anatomy seems to suggest to a lot
of people something more like the
American morbidity Museum and American
Horror Story and so people will come in
and be like where the dead babies like
no we don't you know have dead babies
here there's two parts in the museum
there's the temporary exhibition which
is always borrowed from different
private collectors and there's this
rumor in which is the morbid anatomy
library I think a lot of people who like
this this project are people who had to
choose at a certain point between art
and science I always wanted to be a
scientist and I want it to be an artist
so I'm always interested and drawn to
artifacts from time periods before those
things were divided up these ideas that
death and beauty art and science cute
and horrific have to be separate when I
was a kid I loved animals and I loved
live animals I loved my cat but also I
loved looking at animals the Natural
History Museum or no jarn formaldehyde
my college friends would call me morbid
because I like to pick up roadkill and
preserve the skins
I never stopped doing it but I was
cognizant of the fact that people
thought I was a freak really for
starting the museum that's when I really
discovered there's so many more people
like me than I ever suspected
[Music]
I've been shot on the street stabbed in
prison been a victim of a slashing twice
actually dead in the morgue died in a
supermarket from overeating my name is
Ali Murray
I am a actor and I have played a dead
body on several occasions the director
usually tells you to hold still try your
best to hold your breath it's good to
slow your breathing down beforehand kind
of like yoga or meditation played a
corpse in the morgue on Law & Order
laying down on cold metal while you know
you're practically wearing nothing is
it's bone-chilling and to say the least
you can take short breaths but they
still don't want to see your chest going
up and down at a distance they're like
in a second you sure that guy's been
back there he's breathing
whenever you end up dying on camera or
playing dead on camera it brings you to
another emotional state normally people
don't think if I was shot or stabbed
what would I do but once you're there
and you're playing it it's kind of a
little traumatic you feel bad for people
when you see real people get hurt you
take it in a different you know you see
it in a different way you know my kids
watch it sometimes and they're like dad
you're dead
they killed you like no I'm here with
you now I'm okay
in Guanajuato Mexico there is a museum
filled entirely with mummies
[Music]
mi nombre es Paloma robas lacayo yo l
a-- director adel museo de las mamiya's
de guanajuato el museo de las Diez de
guanajuato es un presento Salgado kxe
hay una elección pneumonias Naturalis
with 117 bodies in total the museum has
the largest collection of natural
mummies in the world the mummies are the
well-preserved remains of people who
died during a cholera outbreak in Mexico
in the 1800s the museum is a haunting
and eerie experience for visitors an
opportunity to stare death in the face
Verena buskers experiencia intima sa
encuentro Mistico con la muerte que
propecia la reflection enter no a la
intención Protea vida y Ascencio de la
misma es importante que las personas
NOLA tengan miedo la muerte yell
contrary oh lewb a common phenomena
natural como una transición inevitable
adesso existential porque finalmente 7
encontrar Konoha it's November 6th 1814
in the belgian city of de Nantes and a
modest house built on his Street that
would later bear his name a tough Sachs
was born 28 years later while living in
Paris Sachs would invent the saxophone
and revolutionized music in ways he
couldn't imagine but this isn't that
story this is the story of how a tough
sax
escaped death seven times before mending
the saxophone
hardly old enough to stand the young
Adolf fell down three flights of stairs
stone floor broke his fall the age of
three ate off swallowed a bowl of water
down sulfuric acid mistaking it for milk
years later a dolphin them talked up a
bit too close to a gunpowder explosion
he was again burned when a cast-iron
frying pan was knocked over under later
a roof stone fell on his head leaving a
lifelong scar a tough once nearly
asphyxiated and when recently varnished
items were left in his bedroom overnight
he woke up barely playing with friends
in a nearby river Adolf was swept up in
a swift current and nearly drowned again
he survived
[Music]
On February 7th 1894 enough died
peacefully in Paris the saxophone had
already crossed the Atlantic primed to
evolve into an icon of American jazz
music and guarantying sax his
immortality
[Music]
kkoma is a very unique community
[Music]
we have a million and a half underground
residents and 1711 results we have
become the city of souls
[Music]
my name is Pat Hatfield and I'm the
retired historian French town of Coleman
I have lived here now for 65 years since
1950 we have now 17 cemeteries I call us
the United Nations or cemeteries because
we have a cemetery for everyone we have
for instance we have for Jewish
cemeteries we have a Catholic cemetery a
Greek cemetery and the dying cemetery
[Music]
and we even have a bit cemetery we have
very things people like Wyatt Earp and
Joe DiMaggio and William Randolph Hearst
and just goes on we inherited hundreds
of thousands of body because during the
gold rush so many gold miners came here
and with them they bought so many
diseases the San Francisco recently had
27 cemeteries and they were full when
the city fathers said our land must be
for the living not for the dead
so an eviction nose was fast in 1914 and
the bodies were slowly transferred here
to coma
the color residents really respect our
cemeteries but we call the mark parks
that's what they are we picnic then we
walk in them our children playing them
they're just a part of us we do have a
slower pulse here almost dead but
[Music]
Fedele funa funa sorry
yet irritants a sonata mnemonics up a
salmon in the limo much olive oil
[Music]
Giovanelli Rhema density rice Rayleigh
miss you opal on a Cosmo no Ariela
return the matter a fossil
turning of the bones or fama daeun is a
funeral tradition of the Malagasy people
and Madagascar on the fifth seventh or
ninth anniversary of a death
the remains of family members are dug up
from their crypt and rewrapped
it's a celebration that lasts multiple
days
[Music]
lasagna retina a moose and ombo fofo
underlay rosin only facile city metaphor
simile lumber retail for fertility
parrot attorney Arizona
if loosen a lumber for four days only a
fat ogre little told herself
[Music]
the event is larger than a wedding or
even a funeral as the family have years
of notice everyone is expected to attend
Yuma's and M muhammediye Nadja total way
she Farina feel like a phenom arm our
physical self a colada for human [ __ ]
father tearfully no whistle la lune an
emission from diesel emission Quran
missions each they were some FAL falater
a monochrome Nuala diesel emission a our
paneer animal a perennial policeman deal
someone who's eaten a Tony Danza city
and she fell in earnings
[Music]
Marla we're gonna be living meat motto
atrocity
I'm to lose Anna Khalil phosphatase
anomaly anomaly moppet or TOEFL the
families and the eternally fresh Sakina
meters early omelet ironic liver fat
isn't a socially fair unless an
accordion
[Music]
you